and michael uh all the comments seem to
be at the moment that the ukrainians are
trapped around several donetsk is that
true
uh yes jane it is in the sense that
sarah donetsk is becoming a trap in
itself and to put it in context it's
part of a bigger trap because the
russians have got three sides of a trap
ready they're trying to spring it in
effect on the northern side
which is where lyman is
they would like to move down to to cut
that salient off in the southern side in
papasna they would like to move
northward so it would make sense for the
russians to try to close that little gap
west of severe donetsk and trap
ukrainian forces who are in the city and
next door will might
go to next door to alicia
but the ukrainians know that they've got
time the russians can't close this trap
very quickly they're moving really
slowly and so getting those two jaws the
northern jaw and the southern jaw to
actually close is very difficult for
them and the ukrainians obviously figure
that the longer they hold out of silver
yonetsk then the more time they will
actually have to withdraw westwards
which is what i suspect they will have
to do at some point but at the moment
they're certainly making the russians
pay for the time that they're having to
spend taking severe donetsk so what is
actually happening inside uh several
nests the chemical plant there does seem
to be important
yes it does the uh the chemical plant
has now become the last redoubt it looks
as if there are about 500 or more
civilians in the plant the ukrainian
army is in the plant as well and it's a
bit like the azov style steel works were
in mariopol it's become the center of an
area that is very hard for the russians
to take but the ukrainians are able to
defend it as it more symbolically than
anything else there's a little bit of um
a film that's come in the russian video
uh and we can't verify the the source of
the video or entirely the the time frame
of it but this is it seems a a russian
video of the uh azat's uh chemical works
under attack you get the sense of it
there also you can see the hills behind
it if you look behind the chemical plant
those are the hills the other side of
lichishansk and those are the hills
behind which the ukrainians may well be
able to retreat and form another line of
defense as and when they decide that
they've spent enough time there and held
up the russians as long as they possibly
can so would you say that really is the
essence of the battle now
well that's part of the battle in in the
donbass and that's still got a long way
to go but let's not forget what's
happening down in the southwest because
the ukrainians are conducting quite a
big offensive maybe to take back
kershawn they've opened up a front on on
a 50-mile front to the the north east of
kershaw north and northeast of kershawn
and there are reports over the last 24
hours so far
not completely confirmed but there's a
lot of these unconfirmed reports that
the ukrainians may have got as far as
kislevika which is uh quite close to
kershaw itself and they may be within
striking distance of novoca clover
which is the
dam which controls the water supply into
crimea the ukrainians would love to
retake that and be back in control of
that water supply so those two areas
we're keeping a very close eye on
because that battle is developing so far
in ukraine's favor
as the days go on